bonsoir à tous tout d'abord il ya des
motivations profondes à rechercher vous
verrez cet après-midi les motivations
des uns des autres et sa part souvent
très loin et peut-être de l'enfance et
comme je disais je suis né en 1960 1962
dire qu'un petit garçon car entre 5 et
10 ans c'était dans les années 68 70
sont les années où il ya trois
événements que je retiens c'est un petit
peu flou mais devient conquête spatiale
avec le premier voyage vers la lune en
décembre 68
il y avait on a marché sur la lune en
juillet 69
et puis à côté de ça il y avait jean
entendait parler chirurgie à coeur
ouvert
coeur ouvert le coeur ouvert et pis
c'est tout et puis un troisième
événement qui m'avait marqué aussi
c'était à la transat en solitaire de
tabarly un gars qui avait pas de balise
radio qui par atlantique nord dans le
brouillard entre on pense qu'il est
perdu et ils émergent à newport en
sortant des bruits mais il ya en prêt en
pôle position des petits événements
comme ça et puis après j'ai suivi un
circuit classique qui m'amène à faire
mes études de médecine
et puis de la chirurgie et puis cette
chirurgie très rapidement je me tourne
vers la chirurgie cardiaque
ça se trouve pas comme ça mais on prend
vraiment petit à petit la mesure de ce
choix
ce choix pour aboutir progressivement à
j'ai pris en charge le programme de
transplantation cardiaque en 1995 à
l'hôpital broussais la morphologie du
professeur carpentier et puis très
rapidement on se rendait compte que la
transplantation cardiaque c'est de
relever un défi le moule ville de
relever le défi de l'insuffisance
cardiaque
et je vous rappelle que les maladies
cardiovasculaires c'est la première
cause de mort bieber talité mortalité et
morbidité c'est-à-dire fait avant la
mortalité
c'est à dire toutes les complications de
la science cardiaque mais c'est la
première cause au monde dans tous les
pays qui ont accès à des systèmes de
soins et qui ont dépassé les problèmes
infectieux la malnutrition et c est
cette insuffisance cardiaque c'est
vraiment l'ultime évolution de ce
maladies cardiovasculaires avec une
mortalité extrêmement précoce chez les
patients auxquels on va s'adresser sont
des patients si on ne fait rien ils sont
morts dans les deux à trois mois
c'est à dire qu'il faut agir vite et
avoir quelques
chose de construit une solide le
traitement idéal c'est la
transplantation cardiaque avec ses
limites et la première limite c'est
l'insuffisance de greffons disponibles
l'insuffisance d'accessibilité à la
transplantation la transplantation en
chiffres on est je sais pas combien
actuellement sur terre 3 4 5 milliards
bientôt 6 milliards vous voyez ces 4000
transplantation cardiaque au monde
4000 pour plusieurs milliards
d'individus en france c'est 360 360
transplantation cardiaque par an une par
jour
10% des transplantations cardiaques
mondiale ça veut dire que cette
transplantation cardiaque ne couvre que
cinq à sept pour cent des besoins de
patients qui pourraient bénéficier de
quelque chose ça veut dire que l'on
laisse de côté plus 90% des patients 90
93 % à qui on ne peut rien proposer
quelques médicaments et on sait que ça
va mal se finir dans les mois qui
suivent
alors on ne peut pas rester insensible
bien entendu à une situation comme celle
là et c'est la raison pour laquelle les
programmes de d'abord d'assistance
circulatoire pour aider un coeur malade
puis de mise au point de coeur
artificiel
voiron un écho suffisamment important
pour intéresser l'ensemble de la
communauté pour mener des projets tels
que le projet car bat un juste un petit
rappel je sais que vous êtes féru
d'anatomie notamment d'anatomie
cardiaque
mais permettez-moi de vous rappeler deux
trois petites choses sur les connexions
et la connexion essentielle c'est de se
souvenir qu'un coeur c'est surtout une
pompe et c'est surtout le ventricule
gauche qui est la pompe qui vous permet
d'éjecter le sens de votre coeur
jusqu'au bout de vos orteils le
ventricule droit il est important il un
petit peu accessoire et tout le reste
est un petit peu accessoire est
d'ailleurs dans toutes les techniques de
transplantation eh bien on remplace
finalement le massif ventriculaire et
non pas le reste du coeur et ça va être
le cas également pour ce que rare typhi
ciel alors comment en est on arrivé à ce
projet de coeur artificiel
eh bien il ya deux personnes importantes
qui sont à l'origine du projet en haut à
droite le professeur alain carpentier
qui j'ai travaillé depuis maintenant
plus de 25 ans et qui est déjà un
pionnier de la chirurgie cardiaque
puisque c'est lui qui a mis au point des
valves cardiaques qu'on appelle les
bioprothèses dévale biologique qui
étaient d'abord des valves de port vous
avez tous entendu dire qu'on implante à
une valve de porc alors je vous rassure
le port ça fait 30 ans qu'on utilise
plus mais maintenant ce sont des valves
qui sont en tissu péricardique d'origine
bovine qui sont traités et surtout elles
ont l'immense avantage cdec premièrement
silencieuse et deuxièmement d'éviter la
prise d'un traitement anticoagulant pour
éviter qu'il est petit caillou qui se
forme qui risque de migraine entraîne un
accident vasculaire cérébral et c est
elles permettent donc aux patients
d'avoir une qualité de vie normale
vous avez sans doute croisé peut-être
sans le savoir des gens qui sont
porteurs d'une bioprothèse comme ceux ci
et qui vivent strictement normalement il
peut le faire du sport
s'il se cogne il ne se blesse pas ils
n'ont pas d'hématome et cetera et cetera
et c'est en développant en développant
ce cette notion des mots compatibilité
c'est-à-dire de l'interface du sang avec
le contenant les vals ou un coeur en
développant un coeur qui va être
biologie they en utilisant des valves
comme ça des membranes recouverte de
péricarde qu'on peut espérer réduire
l'utilisation des anticoagulants et les
complications toutes les machines qui
existe en effet il existe des machines
actuellement qu'on appelle soit des
pompes axial les pompes centrifuges
il ya même un coeur mécanique qui existe
depuis les années 80 de 83 mais qui a
ses limites parce qu'il est complètement
mécanique justement et si on n'a pas
autre chose on n'a pas pu aller plus
loin et bien c'est parce qu on se
heurtaient toujours limité aux
complications de ses systèmes mécaniques
et qui à l'arrivée on fait qu'on les a
utilisés en attente de la
transplantation ce qu'on appelle en
bridge vers la transformation et la
révolution le pas technologique que l'on
a proposé de franchir c'est justement de
quitter cela pour passer à quelque chose
de biologie zay
qui deviendrait à ce moment là une
implantation définitive c'est ce qu'on
appelle la destination therapy la
deuxième personne importante c'est jean
luc lagardère jean luc lagardère grands
capitaines d'industrie français qui un
jour en rencontrant pousseur carpentier
discuter puis la discussion voit que
mène à un projet qui serait celui
d'établir un coeur artificiel nouvelle
génération biologie c'est d'une part et
puis d'autre part autorégulé autorégulé
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ah c'est ce
que vous faites en ce moment vous êtes
après le repas vous êtes au repos vous
avez un débit cardiaque assez bas et
puis tout à l'heure vous allez sortir
monter des escaliers repartir en courant
pour mener toutes vos activités vous
allez augmenter votre débit cardiaque
par nécessité et bien jusqu'à maintenant
aucun système était capable de le faire
et on va voir que ce système va
permettre de simuler le coeur normal
alors bien entendu derrière cela vous
avez des contraintes des contraintes
techniques qui étaient contraintes
médicales
la régulation médicale c'est cette
capacité du coeur à s'adapter en
permanence c'est à dire que l'on va
implanter des capteurs à l'entrée à la
sortie de chacun des ventricules le
ventricule droit le ventricule gauche
qui vont permettre aux patients porteurs
de ce coeur s'il désire faire un jogging
et bien enceinte battement de s'adapter
à sa situation hémodynamique c'est à
dire les règles de la physique qui font
que le coeur peut travailler tels qu'ils
travaillent et en marchant vite en
commençant à courir
on a un besoin supplémentaire de 100 les
pressions vont alors augmenté dans le
ventricule droit est enceinte battement
en étant relié à des logiciels
informatiques
eh bien ces capteurs vont augmenter le
débit cardiaque du coeur pour permettre
aux patients de courir
le deuxième élément c'est
l'hémocompatibilité je vous en ai parlé
ce sont les bioprothèses c'est la
biologisation la prothèse le troisième
élément gelé effleuré également c'est ce
qu'on appelle la destination therapy
c'est à dire que maintenant pour la
première fois d'entrée de jeu on propose
une prothèse qui va être en implantation
définitive on n'attend pas un greffon
derrière non c'est une implantation
définitive il faut valider donc un
concept suffisamment longs et fiable
dans le temps et enfin les contraintes
anatomique c'est bien entendu
le choeur puis s'est implanté dans la
poitrine d'un patient et tenir dans ce
top sales en voici le principe de
fonctionnement de cette prothèse
vous avez en bleu le ventricule droit en
rouge le ventricule gauche et vous voyez
vous avez une membrane qui est activée
de façon alternative et elle est activée
par un liquid liquid qui est une huile
de silicone huile de silicone qui est mû
par deux moteurs un moteur principal à
moteur accessoires qui vont permettre de
pousser le sens du ventricule vers
l'éjection aortique en ayant activé
c'est de membranes alors ce que a cette
prothèse
maintenant que je vous ai parlé des
principes voilà ce qu'elle donne vous
avez deux membranes vous avez quatre
valves bioartificiels et tout ceci est
régulé avec qu'on appelle une
électronique embarquée et ça c'est le
bénéfice direct de jean luc lagardère
qui a mis à disposition des médecins et
des chirurgiens une équipe d'ingénieurs
aéronautiques qui faisait d'abord des
missiles et puis maintenant qu'ils se
mettent à faire un coeur artificiel et
on a une électronique embarqué qui
permet à ce coeur de battre comme un
coeur vous voyez normal on a
l'impression de voir les battements du
coeur et c'est la réalité des choses
alors rassurez vous je vais pas vous
montrer trop d'image de chirurgie et de
sang après le repas mais retenez que
dans les techniques d'implantation ce
qui a motivé le très technique
d'implantation
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que le
coeur c'était surtout un ventricule
gauche à ventricule droit
eh bien il faut comme dans une
transplantation normal retirez les
ventricules malade on implante un
système de fixation une espèce de grosse
agrafes métalliques si j'ose dire sur
laquelle on va venir fixer le port le
moteur sur ce massif atriale ici avec un
cordon qui est encore une des limites
malheureusement c'est l'alimentation en
énergie avec un cordon qui traverse la
peau pour être relié à des batteries
externes pour l'instant la technologie
ne nous permet pas de supprimer cet
élément là mais je ne doute pas qu'à
l'avenir les jeunes générations
travaille dans ce sens et nous
permettent d'aller plus loin et enfin de
connecter les deux gros vaisseaux que
son l'artère pulmonaire et l'aorte
ça vous dit peut-être pas grand-chose
l'objectif de la mise au point de cette
technique c'était que tous les
chirurgiens cardiaques du monde soit
capable de reproduire ce système
facilement et donc d'être le plus proche
possible de ce qu'ils connaissent
actuellement pour pouvoir permettre le
développement de ce programme
alors vous avez bien entendu
une étape indispensable qui a été
d'abord validée sur le cadavre puisqu'un
l'anatomie humaine ont été obligés bien
entendu de valider les techniques puis
de valider sur des animaux pour pouvoir
valider la fiabilité du système et c'est
ce qui nous a permis d'obtenir après
cela les autorisations administratives
notamment auprès de l'asn
l'agencé nationale de la sécurité du
médicament qui est l'organisme
régulateur et qui surveille bien entendu
toutes ces études et cela nous a permis
d'arriver à la première implantation qui
a eu lieu le 18 décembre 2013
vous en avez entendu parler cette
première implantation est encore une
prouesse des ingénieurs de chez quart
matt car maggio rappel c'est la
contraction de carpentier de matra matra
c'était ce qui était avant eads et avant
airbus est bien la première avancée ces
sont les comptes validés les contraintes
anatomique valider les contraindra
d'atomic qu'est ce que cela veut dire
et bien cela veut dire de vérifier bien
entendu avant l'intervention que la
prothèse que là on va pouvoir implanter
tiennent dans le thorax du patient
c'était possible grâce à des logiciels
d'implantation virtuel ou à partir du
scanner du patient en lui même on va
simuler l'implantation pour s'assurer
qu'il n'y ait pas de conflit entre les
cours et le sternum avec cette prothèse
qui risquerait de venir gêner son
fonctionnement
ça c'est une chose essentielle et vous
avez ici les deux scanners des deux
patients qui ont été implantés c'est une
notion qui est essentiel alors une fois
que ces études ont pu être mené les
autorités administratives ont bien
entendu des règles imposent des règles
et les critères de succès pour ce qu'on
appelle l'étude de faisabilité qui
compte sur l'implantation de quatre
patients on en a implanté deux c'est que
on est une survie
30 jours ce qui est court mais
souvenez-vous sont des patients qui sont
condamnés à un mois deux mois trois mois
et d'autre part que l'on ait aucun
problème justement de formation de
caillots à l'intérieur de la prothèse ou
d'envoi de caillots dans le cerveau et c
est dans ce sens on a validé ces deux
implantations puisque le premier patient
vous voyez ici à la cafétéria en train
de prendre un petit café avec le présent
carpentier a survécu 74 jours chez
quelqu'un qui étaient assez âgés
puisqu'il avait 76 ans et a permis de
valider ce premier cas en remplissant
tous les critères de succès
malheureusement il est décédé au bout de
soixante quatorze jours et à l'issue de
ce décès ça nous a permis d'analyser ce
qui s'était passé de comprendre de
modifier et ce qui nous a permis tout de
suite de transformer l'essai avec la
deuxième implantation qui a eu lieu à
nantes le 5 août dernier chez un patient
qui est maintenant à plus de sept mois
de survie alors qu'ils étaient condamnés
à moins d'un mois et chez un patient qui
a pu rentrer chez lui maintenant depuis
le début de l'année on a donc fait une
avancée déjà essentiel bien entendu on
travaille sur les implantations à venir
numéro 3 numéro 4 qui tireront bien
entendu le bénéfice des deux premières
implantations les configurations de
machines que l'on utilise
vous avez la prothèse ici qui est encore
reliée par un câble percutanée a ici un
module de régulation et une console
relativement encore importante pour la
partie hospitalière mais qui peut être
transformé par un système portable qui
pèse 3 kg avec lequel vous avez ce petit
module plus de batterie de 3 heures
d'autonomie chacune est probablement
alors et un an si vous n'avez sans doute
pas croiser ce patient dans la rue mais
vous seriez un entre peut-être que vous
l'auriez croiser quelqu'un qui se
promène avec un petit sac en bandoulière
ou un petit sac à dos on en voit
tellement vous avez sans doute déjà
peut-être croisé un patient qui était
porteur d'un système pas celui là mais
ça viendra sans doute dans l'avenir sans
vous en rendre compte
alors ce que ratifie ciel car matt c'est
un projet c'est un défi
c'est un défi à plusieurs points
premièrement un défi on a vu
industrielles techniques qui n'a été
rendue possible par les progrès de
l'informatique par la miniaturisation
globale par l'utilisation de matériaux
composites de matériaux biologiques
c'est un projet également est un défi
économique parce que vous pouvez
comprendre que c'est un un espèce de
chalenge qui coûte très cher et grâce à
un montage un petit peu original dont on
n'a pas beaucoup l'habitude en france
alliant des capitaux publics avec
beaucoup de capitaux privés a permis
d'arriver à cette première implantation
et de faire un saut technologique très
important puisque on a vraiment quitté
les anciennes générations de systèmes
d'assistance qui n'allait pas plus loin
parce qu'on n'avait rien d'autre à
proposer et tous les anciens systèmes
étaient en butée sur quelque chose et
c'est sans doute ce pas du coeur carmat
qui permettent de faire une transition
finalement d'un millénaire à l'autre et
d'ouvrir les innovations technologiques
d'avenir administratif chez mais
également le fait de travailler avec les
équipes de la haine s m quelquefois
l'administration nous freine beaucoup en
france on râle après l'administration
mais on a rencontré des équipes qui nous
ont soutenus dans le projet et qui nous
ont aidés pour avancer et le m le faire
naître et enfin ça soulève un certain
nombre de problèmes dont des problèmes
éthiques bien entendu vous avez vu les
discussions qui lie à l'assemblée
actuellement sur l'euthanasie est un
nazi active etc etc
on n'est pas dans le cadre de
l'euthanasie mais il est certain que
d'implanter des machines de façon
définitive posera tôt ou tard des
problèmes éthiques de savoir quand
est-ce que l'on déclare la mort d'un
patient qui doit arrêter une machine le
jour on doit l'arrêter parce que les
autres organes sont défaillants c'est
sans doute des propositions dans
lesquels la société devra avancer devra
comprendre pour pouvoir permettre le
développement de tels projets mais la
société n'aura pas le choix et elle
devra avancer dans ce sens là tout ceci
sans oublier que c'est au service de la
vie humaine de l'universalité de la
médecine
je vous remercie de votre attention